this morning through a unique test of
partisanship we are finding out that
Democrats and Republicans are not just
deeply divided on the facts they may be
actually seeing two completely different
worlds now there's Gallop Poland going
back two decades that shows a stark and
widening divide on a variety of
political issues but now a growing
number of researchers are coming around
to the idea that politics actually
Alters our perception it changes what we
see we decided to put that idea to the
test
they want to destroy this country if
you've been following politics this year
this President is a vindictive man he's
determined to stoke Division and Chaos
he's in his damn basement again you're
a you may find yourself wondering what
exactly is wrong with people all they
can do is spew hatred are they just not
seeing what you're seeing fascists
ruining this country well we decided to
find out we're going to show you two
video clips and you just tell us what
you see we'll do we showed identical
Clips to both Trump supporters and Biden
supporters starting with this clash
between police and black lives matter
protesters almost everybody had a strong
reaction it's terrible this is awful
this shouldn't be but when we asked a
question designed to test their
political filter their answers could not
have been more different who do you
think is being more aggressive I would
have to say the protest is cuz they're
not letting him go through who would you
say is being the aggressor there um NYPD
the police not the protesters right the
uh rioter they're not protesters they're
rioting as far as I can see there's no
violence or anything from the protesters
and police are acting a little violently
the protesters that that they're
challenging you they're challenging the
cops okay come on do it seems to me like
uh NYPD showing a little lack of
restraint in their crowd control frankly
it was the same with this video a
well-known confrontation between armed
homeowners and demonstrators marching
past their house oh is that what I think
it is this is so wrong once again people
from different political parties were
seeing very different things these
people are just sitting there protecting
their house they don't want to they
don't want to shoot nobody they don't
want to harm nobody they're sitting
there strictly protecting their house if
you had to pick the person being more
aggressive or the people being be the
person with the gun yes it would be the
person with the gun they defend
what they could while they were there
I'm not against it so in terms of who's
being aggressive it's the the protesters
protesters who's being more aggressive
oh the person with the assault rifle
without a question in fact there was
only one thing everyone seemed to agree
on do you think America is becoming more
politically divided yes yes that's for
sure absolutely yeah cuz we're so
freaking polarized so this is a problem
that's getting worse yeah it's getting
worse and I don't see it un winding
anytime soon jay van bille is a
professor of psychology at New York
University political identities are one
of the most important and Powerful
identities that people have right now in
this country and that's grown over time
how did that happen our political
leaders stopped cooperating and voting
in different ways the media that we tune
into uh you can now select media that
aligns with your political identities
and social media allows you to tune in
to whatever you want to tune into
whatever you hope to see and so you can
confirm all your beliefs and identity
and Expectations by plugging into these
different realities that can make it
harder to understand why others would
view things so differently can you
imagine a Democrat looking at the videos
you you saw and coming to the complete
opposite conclusion no I can't no I
can't so this is known as What's called
the bias blind spot that it's really
easy for us to see bias in other people
but it's hard for us to see it in
ourself even though other people around
us are friends and family and colleagues
can see when we're biased we have a hard
time seeing it we think we're rational
what does it mean for our government for
our democracy for our country if we
can't look at a shared reality if you
don't see the same facts you can't have
a serious discussion about how to come
to some solution some things are very
clear but most things are ambiguous and
so we have to decide how we're going to
interpret them and you can interpret
them through an extreme partisan lands
and decide anybody who doesn't see
reality the same way you do is an evil
person that needs to be defeated or you
could pause and ask yourself am I seeing
it the right way am I seeing it the only
way and why are they seeing it
differently than me yeah the key there
is pause yes yeah pause and ask yourself
what are you looking at and are you
seeing it the right way is there another
way to look at it but the reality is
that in the moment we're living in you
can show people the very same video and
they can come to opposite points of
opinion on it to that point of pausing
social media works so quickly and people
react so fast that there isn't a lot of
pausing anymore in fact quite the
opposite there's a lot of rushing to
conclusions and judgments the bias blind
spot is very scary but when the
professor said if you don't see the same
facts that's the thing Tony how do we
get past this if we don't even see the
same facts how do we run a government if
we don't have a shared reality and then
each of us believe deeply that we are
seeing the truth and everyone else is
crazy but we've got to ask ourselves
maybe we have it wrong well and you have
to I think it's very important and
because this is part of the job that we
have to do sometimes is is you have to
look at something and go all right why
does this person see this so differently
what do they see that I don't I am not
seeing it's part of why the virus is so
bad right now is because it it separates
us and the only way to get past this is
through conversation it's to meet people
who have that opposite point of view and
to talk to them but it's really hard it
reminds me of marital counseling where
you'd be on a rant and the counselor
would say but that's your reality that's
not his reality and my thing but he's
wrong he reminds me a lot of marital
family it does cuz we're looking at the
same thing like the proof is right there
that's very very fascinating I I wonder
how you get past that that's
conversation mine was divorce I don't
recommend that so you got to figure out
something else people you got well we
tried that once it was called the Civil
War not so well we got to work this out
yeah